- Where did you get cadavers?
- I don't blame you guys around
understanding cause you guys
haven't seen the amount of Tai
Lopez courses that I've seen.
- Ha, he said Tai Lopez!
I've made a video reacting
to unprofessional medical TikToks.
How about funny ones?
I'm sure there's some
funny ones out there.
Let's go searching, pew!
- This is my first time.
I can't, I don't know how to do this.
It's, ooh!
Golly, I ain't trying to do that!
- This is questionable.
- (laughs) "This is questionable."
Honestly, the first time
you do an ultrasound,
it is confusing.
I can relate to that struggle.
That jelly, just so cold when it hits
the bare skin.
(jelly squelches)
Urgh.
- Doctor, something's wrong with me!
- Explain to me what's wrong.
- When I touch my head, it hurts.
When I touch my nose, it hurts.
When I touch my elbow, it hurts.
- I now see your problem.
- Oh no, am I gonna die?
- No, your fingers broken.
- Ha ha, I did not expect that!
People are so much wittier than I am.
That's so good, I thought
she was gonna make a joke
about fibromyalgia, and
I was gonna get upset,
like you shouldn't make fun of patients,
and she said your finger (laughs) hurts.
That's really good.
Also, there's a play on that doctor's joke
where it's like, "Doctor,
hurts when I do this."
"Oh okay, don't do this, copay."
- Hi, I'm Dr. Jones.
I'm an ob-gyn physician.
I'll tell you what I did today,
but you have to listen fast.
I put on a mask because COVID.
I got some coffee because
I'm addicted to caffeine.
After that, I went to the operating room
and did two surgeries,
one major, one minor,
before having socially-distanced chips
for lunch and doing an HSG.
I'll tell you what that is another day.
I went to my clinic and saw patients,
pregnant and not pregnant,
and then I went to my office
and I (inhales) charted forever,
and then I went to labor and delivery,
and we delivered a baby,
and it was super fun,
and now I'm going home
because I'm exhausted.
- Mama Doctor Jones is a champ,
not only because of everything
she does in her life
and doing it quite well.
She's amazing at TikTok.
It's a really good representation
of how hard it is to be a doctor,
especially one who's seeing patients
in a clinic setting,
but also is a surgeon.
It's not an easy life.
Mama Doctor Jones is up to the challenge.
If you haven't seen our collab,
I'm linking it down below.
- But sorry, bro, your daddy's dead.
- Aw man!
- Calm down, man.
I'm the one that should be upset.
I had to go on break right after.
You know how hard it
is to eat a sloppy joe
after seeing blood?
- Did he go quick?
- Oh nah, he took his time.
I'm like, "Hurry up, I'm
trying to go on break."
He fighting, I'm like, "Let go, man,
"you got God on hold, man."
- Did he suffer?
- Oh, most definitely
'cause he was screaming.
I'm like, "Man, this is annoying"
'cause I know the other
patient's trying to sleep.
I'm on the phone trying to
talk to my insurance agency,
trying to get my insurance
lower, but he yelling,
they can't hear me, I'm like, "Shut up."
If it makes you feel better,
I'm sure Mr. Johnson is in a better--.
- Wait, my dad's last name is Wilson.
- Oh, your last name Wilson?
Aw, my fault.
Your daddy straight, brah, he outside.
Hey, you Mr. Johnson son?
- Yeah.
- Your daddy's dead.
- Oh, thank you.
- You welcome.
- That was rough.
I have to say
name mistakes in hospitals do happen.
This is a real issue.
In fact, when we have two people
either with the same last name
or a last name that sounds similar,
we put on our floors name alerts.
It says name alert above the patient's bed
and when you enter the room
so that these mistakes don't
happen, and when people
are creating the person's chart,
it has a name alert on it.
It's like a bright sticker
so that you're checking
the right person's name.
- Hey, doctor, what's that thing?
- Great question, young man.
That would be the heart.
- Hey, doc--
- Scalpel.
- Of course.
Doctor, I was wondering
if that was the right coronary artery.
- No, that is a circumflex artery.
Get out of the OR.
- Some doctors, especially surgeons,
can be quite mean to
residents and students,
but they're really nice
to those who are shadowing
trying to decide whether or no
they wanna go into the field
because they don't wanna scare them away,
plus it's also fair to say that
they're under no obligation
to know all the important arteries.
That person did ask what that
is, and it was the heart.
Eh, the one thing that I will
say with quiet certainty,
and it's all jokes aside,
is we need to end that toxic culture
of attacking residents and students,
that if they don't know
something they're dumb
or they're evil or we
need to kick them out.
That doesn't really work.
It doesn't motivate you to do better.
It actually kind of puts you
down and demotivates you.
It's no good for anybody.
- My Harvard days were my peak.
God, those days were fun.
- Dr. Welch, where'd you
go to medical school?
- I actually didn't go to school.
Learned everything I know
through YouTube tutorials and eBooks.
(doctors laugh)
No, no, I'm serious.
I literally don't have
a legal medical degree
'cause everything that I
was learning in school,
I was like, I can just
learn this on my own,
so that's what I did, I studied on my own,
and I worked on cadavers outta my garage.
I'm like the Mark
Zuckerberg of doctor people.
- Where did you get cadavers?
- And how are you the medical director
at a children's hospital?
It's illegal to operate without a license.
- Is it illegal to save
a dying child's life?
- Yeah, for you it is.
- Dr. Welch, where did you get cadavers?
- I don't blame you guys
for not understanding
'cause you guys haven't seen the amount
of Tai Lopez courses that I've seen.
- Ha, he said, "Tai Lopez
courses," oh my God.
Honestly, there's a lot
you can learn online,
and I feel like I'm about
to release some merch soon,
some limited edition merch,
about how much education
you can get online,
specifically from watching my videos,
but so far, this is
hilarious, let's keep playing.
- Knowledge will take you so far in life
without a college degree.
For example, every child that I save
represents a new Lamborghini
that comes into my life,
which is why I have 43
Lamborghinis in my garage.
- You took Tai Lopez courses
to learn how to be an open heart surgeon?
- Gary Vaynerchuk was also
a very large influence.
(door crunches)
- President's daughter
has a puncture aorta.
You two, sit the (beep) down.
Dr. Welch, get in that operating room
and save the president's daughter's life.
- Ah yeah, medicine is
one of those things where,
why am I even explaining this?
Yeah, you can't practice
medicine without a license,
and it's not because the license
is some kind of magical paper
that actually proves you're capable,
but when you're about to trust
someone with your health,
you hope that they've been
experienced, they've practice,
they've learned, they show
competency in these fields.
So yeah, you want someone who's not only
showing you a medical school diploma,
but also a residency
graduation certificate,
a board certification.
I'm board certified in family medicine.
I have a medical license
in New York and New Jersey.
They ask you a lotta questions
about criminal backgrounds.
Where did this guy get a cadaver?
- Would you mind?
(door knocks)
- Yeah.
- Your patient is ready.
- All right, be there in a second.
- Breath!
(doctor laughs)
- There's one more part we can take--
- [Man] Your patient is waiting.
- Oh, my bad.
- No, as funny as that is,
that's now what happens.
Dude, if we sat and watched
SpongeBob or whatever
for 45 minutes before
going to see patients,
we would be five hours
late to each patient.
Think about it this way.
I go into a room with a patient.
Technically, I'm scheduled for 15 minutes.
My nurse has to be in there
for the first five minutes
gathering the chief complaint,
asking some basic
questions, doing the vitals.
That's five minutes.
Now I have 10 minutes with the patient.
Let's say a walk in exactly on time.
I introduce myself to the patient.
I ask them what they're here for.
I ask them their name.
I do a proper greeting to make sure
that we're on the same page.
I ask them what's bothering them.
I ask some follow up question.
I figure out how long it's been an issue,
what other things run in their family.
I look at their prescription medications.
I decide to do a physical exam,
do a few things to make sure
I'm ruling out conditions
that could be otherwise
threatening to their health
and to figure out what exactly
I think could be going on.
I then sit onto the computer,
and I explained to them
what is going on.
I explain to them my treatment plan.
I make sure they understand.
I have them repeat back to me
the same set of instructions
so we're on the same page.
I then placed the orders in the computer
so that they have their medications ready
or treatment ready when
they leave the office.
I then go back to my area,
waiting to see the next patient.
How much time do you think has gone by?
I didn't even begin to
write this patient's note,
and I can't really wait to
do it at the end of the day
'cause then I'll get home way
later than I'm supposed to
and everyone's mad because
I'm missing schedules,
I'm being late to the next patient,
and it creates a huge hurdle.
The amount of administrative work
that doctors now have to do
is beyond anyone's imagination,
like spending 30 minutes making sure
that my patient gets their medication
'cause I ordered capsules
instead of tablets
happens way too often.
That's why we're late,
not because we're watching SpongeBob
although that is cuter and
funnier to think about.
- All right, so, Chad,
Um, it looks like you've a
minor tear in your bicep,
uh, nothing too severe,
but we're gonna have you
take about a month off
from any physical activities.
Um, we'll bring ya back in,
we'll reevaluate you,
and then we'll clear you
based off of how well, um,
you've recovered, okay.
Sounds good?
Awesome.
- Ha, month off!
Does he not know who I am?
Ha ha, idiot!
Argh!
- The funny part is I love
that he's a Bengals fan.
Shout out Cincinnati folks.
This happens a lot.
Most commonly, where it's happened
is around sporting events,
like if someone's training
for the New York City Marathon
and they've come in with a serious injury,
sometimes even though with
something really serious
like a stress fracture,
and I'm like, "Do not run
"under any circumstances
"'cause you could fracture
your shinbone completely."
and people are just like, "I don't care.
"I been training so long I'm doing it."
That's obviously against medical advice.
Usually, they end up hurting themselves.
Bicep injuries, oof, those
can be quite painful.
A minor one, yeah, no big deal,
but I've seen bicep tears
where the bicep actually
ends up like up here.
Urgh, that hurts.
Don't tear your bicep.
Check out these wildly
absurd Instagram health posts
that I react to here,
or if you want a good laugh,
check out my most recent memes video.
Click here for that one or on this one.
Which one you clicking on?
Stay happy and healthy.